[MUSIC]
>> Thank you so much Rick for being here
today.
As you can see we've got a lot of really
interested people in the audience here for
the first view from the top of the year,
so thanks to everybody for being here.
You and I had a chance last week to grab
coffee and I walked away from that
conversation feeling really excited about
what we were gonna talk about here today.
I think you've got an incredible story to
share about leadership at Yale,
which I'm sure everybody's heard of.
Then going into your recent transition to
Coursera,
which is one of the most buzzed about
companies in education today and, and,
lastly, your thoughts on leadership
generally and
advice that you have about lessons you've
learned from your career and
thoughts you'd have to share with our
student community here.
So I'd love to get started by stepping
back to 1993,
to when you were first appointed president
of Yale.
And, in a lot of ways, this was a little
bit of a turnaround situation.
You had a very signficant operating
deficit of about $20 million.
>> Seemed like a lot at the time.
>> A lot at the time, a lot now.
You had strained relationships with the
faculty and I think there were a lot of
questions at that time about where Yale
was going in the future.
So how did you step into that role as
president?
What were your priorities as you thought
about your strategy to
address these issues?
>> Well, you know, looking back, it was.
it's surprising to see that, the, the, the
major initiatives that I
laid out in my inaugural address turned
out to be the things that occupied me for
20 years, so it, some of it was not rocket
science.
Some of it was pretty obvious.
We, we had a really terribly crumbling
physical infrastructure.
Most of Yale was built in the inter-war
period, between World War I and
World War II.
And in collegiate gothic style.
And had not been touched since 1945, so,
or 40.
So there was basically massive amounts of
investment needed to bring the
infrastructure up to decent condition.
And that, that sort of decaying look of
the campus.
And the problematic nature of the city of
New Haven,
which at the time was very high in
unemployment and
the whole central business district,
essentially one third vacant.
Where the crime was, was rampant at an all
time high.
All of these things were causing us to
lose market-share.
For the best students in, in higher
education.
And so Yale was, you know, at edge of the
best in
the world but it risked falling out of
that very top tier of universities.
And so, investment in both infrastructure
and the city were just
looming large as powerful things that
needed to be addressed.
And then there were a couple of things I
saw at that time,
that were longer term that turned out to
be major themes.
One was internationalization, as Eugene
laid out, and thank you,
by the way, Garth, for that generous
undeserved introduction.
But one was internationalization because I
just thought the world was changing and
globalization.
People weren't using the word yet in 1993.
But but, but the phenomenon was, was
clear.
I mean, we needed Tom Friedman to give us
the words, but we, but
we had the song somehow.
And, and and
then the other was redressing the balance
of Yale's strengths and weaknesses.
That is, we had we were in danger of
becoming so tilted towards the humanities,
the social science and the professions and
weaker and weaker in science medicine and
engineering that I felt we needed to sorta
put more balance into that mix.
A lesson, by the way, which Stanford
should learn in the other direction.
>> [LAUGH] Right.
>> If you want my advice.
But, but.
>> We do.
[LAUGH]
>> yeah.
So, so those were the, those were the big
themes.
And the first initiative.
First really major step we're taking
toward urban citizenship in New Haven,
which was a, a major project.
>> And tell us about that.
What did you learn about working with the,
the, the city at that time and
also pitching that to your board and
trying to get buy-in for that effort.
>> Yeah, the board was there.
Because the board was very nervous about
the,
the, the, the sort of reputation of New
Haven as a dangerous place, and so
they were entirely on board with, with
investing significantly in the city.
It was more a question of selling the, the
faculty and the and,
and the local constituents who felt you
know, if Yale starts spending money to
help fix New Haven this was like pouring
money down the drain.
And, and so we didn't start by spending
money.
We started by, by doing other things.
The, the idea was.
It, we had a 200 plus year history of town
gown rivalry, ill will.
Yale had, was this rich ivory tower
institution in a poor and declining
industrial city that, you know, that had
been a prosperous industrial city, but
it was, was in, was in a great decline as
the manufacturing industry went away.
Shirt-making industry went to the south.
The munitions industry at the end of the
Vietnam War basically shut down.
And there was nothing left.
Really nothing left literally.
It was a awful.
So so we had to we, we, we needed to.
We, you know, we knew we, economic
development was gonna be a major theme.
But we couldn't just jump into that.
We were just, we were not trusted.
So the issue was winning the bona fide's
of community leaders.
Of the political apparatus and
of the other community organizations in
the neighborhoods and in the clergy who
have important political influence
particularly in the black community.
So we, we, we set about it by with
volunteerism and really mobilizing.
The, what was already happening,
but organizing it in much more systematic
ways.
So basically, I made, I had every dean of
every school rec, you know,
told that it's part of your job
description to have urban outreach and
to get your students and faculty involved.
So the drama school is doing improv
theaters in near by neighborhood and
the forestry environmental studies schools
planting trees and
creating pocket parks in neighborhoods,
and, and we could go on and on.
All kinds of, of initiatives on parts of
of students and faculty.
And, and after a couple years that, it
really helped, we, we were really kind of,
beginning to win the hearts and minds.
Hey, Yale's different now, it's really
engaged in helping the city and
then being a participating citizen.
And then it was only at that point that
the mayor came to me and said, you know,
we need to fix the downtown and the only,
the only entity in the place with cap,
with the capital and the vision and the
self-interest to make that work is Yale.
So, with my blessing, go ahead and buy
downtown, and redevelop it.
And I mean, that was amazing, just from a
historical point of view,
that we had that opportunity.
But it worked out really well.
And we've got great retail.
Great, great food, you know,
really terrific restaurants in the
downtown New Haven now.
It's actually, truthfully, I hate to say
this, but
it's actually nicer than Harvard Square.
>> [LAUGH] We won't compare.
But you know, I think one thing that you
were saying Rick,
that you know, this, this idea of how you
work with the faculty at your school.
>> Yeah.
>> I think is really interesting.
Faculty are, are, generally tenured.
You can't fire them.
You can't force them to do what you want.
So, how did you go about creating a vision
and
getting them to, to really have a
consensus on that?
>> Well this, it, all, all, this is all
true for
almost any constituency where you need
their support.
I mean, this would be true to any of you
who are leading organizations and
you wanna keep the, you know, your senior
staff with you,
you wanna keep the employees with you.
Basically, a leader needs to articulate a
vision.
He needs to be clearly and coherently
articulated.
It needs to be tested with key people at
the beginning before it's widely
communicated.
But then it's communicate, communicate,
communicate.
I mean it's just getting the message out
and, and going and
patiently talking about it with skeptical
audiences.
Answering questions.
Being, being open and responsive to
suggestions and change.
But also not yielding on the core vision.
And, you know, one,
one of the great things about faculty is
they're basically rational.
And, and even though they're very
independent.
And so, persuading is possible, actually.
>> Mm-hm.
>> If you have,
if you, you know, if it's a compelling
argument eventually, you'll win.
And, and, that, I think that's, that's,
that was the way, you know, for
things like, you know, investing in the
infrastructure, you know, investing in
the city and internationalization, all of
those strategies.
Really became I think a pretty common
consensus with time,
patience, explanation, lots of meetings
with groups to talk it through.
>> Hm, the on, on the topic of
internationalization.
You did face some push back on the
decision by the University to
open a campus in Singapore in partnership
with the National University of Singapore.
There was a lot of question around whether
Yale should be partnering with a country
that had some questionable stands on human
rights in,
in conflict with the way Yale felt.
[CROSSTALK] And so how did you make that
decision to really put
yourself behind that decision, when you
knew there was going to be public outcry?
>> Right, well the si, so the initiative
to start a liberal arts college in
Singapore came very, you know, rather late
in my presidency.
We started talking about it in spring of
2009 after I'd been in my position for
nearly 16 years.
And and it was, it was a kind of
a capstone of a major effort to do a lot
of other things, globally.
Lots of exchange programs.
Research facilities in China, all kinds of
other things have preceded this.
So, the actual internationalization battle
for hearts and
minds within the university had already
been won.
What, what hit the nerve of some of our
faculty, and
I, I hate, leaders will always say this.
But it was a really small minority of
people who were
really exorcised about this.
The majority, as one, as one of my key
advisors,
one faculty member I've greatly respect
said to me about this before it blew up.
He said.
He said you know the thing is you've got
15% of the people wildly enthusiastic
about this and 5% are, are just really
upset about it.
And the remaining 80% actually don't know
or care or just totally indifferent.
He said, what you have to avoid is a
situation where the 5% somehow get
an issue where they can bring, where they
can persuade the 80%.
Well that was so pressured because it
turned out to be what happened.
The, the, the fa, the, these faculty
members tried to pass a resolution
that said we, you know, we support full
human rights in Singapore.
Well, who's gonna vote against that?
Right?
So it wa, it wa,
it was, it, it, it was not that they
censured our doing.
And it was not a vote of no confidence in
our doing it.
It was very clever, and, and you know, so
we took a few lumps in the press on this.
Let me tell you why this is such a great
idea though.
Asia is crying out for
the kind of critic pedagogy that focuses
on critical thinking.
You know, China trains e, enorm, enormous
numbers of engineers and
we, and Americans worry that they're going
to eat our lunch some day because of this.
And they look at us and they say, but
all the innovation in the world is coming
from the United States.
And why?
They have a very different method of
educating people.
They teach people to think for
themselves, to be independent, to question
the teacher.
To, to speak up in class.
To argue.
We need more of that.
And so the Chinese were kinda begging me
to do this.
To set up a liberal arts college within
China.
I thought that was an environment where it
just wasn't ready for, for this kind of,
of really free, free ranging intellectual
battles and questioning authority.
But Singapore frankly for all the
reputation of it of the,
they're trying to maintain a kinda tenuous
hold on a, on a, on what is a peten,
you know, what is essentially an island,
multicultural island in the middle of,
you know of a, a very dif, a very
different, you know,
ethnic pu, composition of Malaysia and
China nearby.
You know, yes the government has been
authoritarian in many ways and
the freedoms that we that we would like to
that we enjoy are not
present entirely there.
But the universities that have always been
in Singapore are kind of
oasis where the rules are different.
And where free speech goes on.
Where academic freedom is practiced and
friends of ours said,
look this, if you are negotiating an
arrangement with the Singaporeans
you can trust them to abide by the,
they'll do, they'll be straight.
If you write it down in contract, they'll
honor it.
And so we wrote, we wrote a great contract
which essentially protects it
academic freedom on the campus.
It doesn't protect students who wanna go
march on the public in the public
square downtown because that's not allowed
in the city.
We have to have a permit.
But, but we can we have them define our
campus as an indoor space.
So it was one was one [UNKNOWN] And just,
just a few weeks ago there was an there
was a good example of this, a film,
with, with this politically, critical of
the, of the ruling party,
was released in Europe, and it was banned
in, for public exhibition in Singapore.
But before the public ban occurred, we had
already assured,
been assured by the government.
That yes, consistent with,
with our understanding, you can show this
on your campus.
So, so we're, I think we've negotiated a
pretty reasonable arrangement, and
by the way, the, it's an incredible, the
students we're getting are amazing.
The curriculum is a prescribed curriculum
that in the first year,
that compares Eastern and Western
intellectual traditions.
In social thought, in literature.
And looks at comparative social
institutions.
It's really a radically different kind of
curriculum.
And we're u, it's all small classes.
All 15 or to 18 students at most, and it's
going great.
>> I wanna go back to-
>> Yeah.
>> Asia in a little bit once we move into
your time at Coursera,
because I know that's a big, a big market
for
you there as well, but after 20 years at
Yale, you ended up retiring in 2013.
That didn't last very long.
>> First course I ever flunked was
retirement.
>> Exactly.
So, so I'm curious, you,
you went from Yale where you had almost
$20 billion endowment and
12,000 students to Coursera where you have
$85 million in venture capital.
And, nine million users at this point?
I don't know what the-
>> 10.
>> North of 10.
>> 10, 10 million users at this point, so
growing exponentially.
That's a, that's a huge change for you.
What made you think, Coursera's the next
step for me?
>> Well I didn't think it when I, when I
left Yale I as president I, I was out
here, visiting as a, a, visiting professor
in economics at, over at [UNKNOWN] and
kind of thought I'd construct a life with
a portfolio of things to do.
Like maybe some, maybe go back, do some
teaching.
Either it's Stanford or Yale or maybe half
and half and, and, then,
then I would you know be on a couple of
boards and
do some public service commissions and
studies and things like that.
So I, I, you know I could see a pretty
full life ahead, but
then I somehow just you know.
Ran into the folks at Kliner-Perkins and
and was convinced you know go,
go, go take a look at this, and
I went over to and signed on as you know
to be a consultant essentially.
Come a week, a month in the last spring
semester, and and I I basically
got seduced in you know, they basically
pitched me on actually we could you know?
We have wonderful co-founders.
They're Stanford professors.
They're brilliant imaginative innovative
but
it we could use a CEO to help take this to
the next level.
And so I succumbed.
And I must say it's more consistent with
what I've been doing for
the last decade or even, even 12, 14
years.
Then I would have initially thought,
that is, I've, the big focus on
internationalization, one of, a-
and, also Yale did play an early role in
online education.
We, we started, with Stanford, as a joint
venture Stanford offered Yale.
We did a little startup in 2000 called
AllLearn.
That was an aesthetic success but a
financial flop.
We had the wrong market.
We, we, we, you know, that's one amazing
thing about technology.
We just sort of, just, we, we, we're
stumbling like every,
all people at the beginning.
And we thought this was really for our
alumni.
Well, that's much too narrow a market
segment.
So Yale, Stanford, and Oxford were putting
on these great courses targeting their
alumni just we just weren't getting
enrollment and sustaining it.
But then in 07 we started with open
educational resources and like M.I.T.
we put a large number of our best courses
on line but
not interactively not like Course Sera.
Not like the current moot.
There was just a camera in the back of a
classroom you know capturing the lectures.
And that was, that was great, it got a lot
of viewership, but, nothing like Coursera,
I mean when Coursera and
Udacity and edX started to operate you
could see that the world had changed.
Internet bandwidth now supported large
scale interactivity.
And it, it's, so, this is,
this is an amazing opportunity to
democratize higher education.
I mean, the reason I'm doing it is not,
not the reason that most presidents and
provosts will tell you that they're doing
it.
Most of them will tell you the main
reason, the main thing that's in it for
me is I can improve on campus teaching.
Gotta get all this data on what works and
what doesn't work, and
I can use it at home.
But, to me, that's like saying the
automobile, when it was invented,
was a good tool for going to the grocery
store, you know.
I mean, it's, it's, it, it misses the
point that, that, that the,
that the scale, itself, is unbelievably
powerful.
And, the idea that a single Stanford
professor, a single Yale professor,
would teach a class, one class for ten
weeks, or eight weeks, and
teach more students in that class than
they would teach in the 30 or
40 year teaching career at home, is
amazing.
It's taking the resources that we, that we
Universities invest in,
great teachers developing their careers,
becoming masters of a subject,
becoming experts and giving that expertise
to the world for free.
I mean, it's truly revolutionary and, and
that's what's exciting about it.
>> It, it is very exciting, but how, how
are you thinking about the research, Rick,
that shows that the primary users of,
of MOOCs at this point are college
educated white males?
That, that sort of is contrater,
contradictory to the goal that you have to
provide access to millions of, of users,
and learners worldwide.
So how are you and Coursera thinking about
that issue?
>> The we are doing all we can to
promote outreach to the populations that
normally wouldn't have access to this.
But th, that is to say,
sort of naturally you'd expect highly
educated, affluent people later in life.
To, to, to sample these courses.
That's sorta obvious, you're all gonna do
it when you're, when,
when you're looking for
something interesting to do when you're 50
years old, you know, apart from your job.
The but the, but the but, but there's, you
know, a couple of things.
So you, it's not surprising there's
penetration there.
But there's a su, an amazing amount of
penetration elsewhere.
I mean, what does it mean to be, to have a
college degree if you're,
if you're from a developing country with
low per capita incomes it prob,
it doesn't mean the same thing in terms of
what you've been exposed to.
As if you've gone to an Ivy League school,
or Stanford, or, or,
or a, a first-rate institution in Europe.
I mean we are giving a lot of value to
people, even if they're college
educated in places where what they got in
college is nothing like what you all got.
So that's one.
T, two is, we are using various tools like
creating live learning hubs in US
embassies around the world.
so where people who don't have the
bandwidth can actually come and
get access to it, and, and, have, have
sort of mentored discussion groups.
The state department is very excited about
this as an outreach, as a way,
of, of, of getting to people in Africa and
the Middle East.
And that's so that's underway.
It's going to spread and
also cellphone technology is getting
bandwidth and it's getting better and
better in developing countries and we're
now optimizing for mobile use.
I mean originally we, well originally four
months ago we, we put, we put ,.
The lectures only.
The videos on, on mobile applications.
And now we realize, people are using it.
30% of the, of our, of our viewership is,
or, of our, of our students are now
accessing via their iPads or their tablets
or their phones.
And so now we're developing by the middle
of next year we'll have completely
full interactivity.
Every, everything you can to do on a
computer,
you'll be able to do on the phone.
>> How are you thinking about who your
main customer is, because you've got
the Universities on the one side that are
putting their content up on your platform?
>> Right.
>> You've got the students who are using
it, and you also have the business
community where you have an opportunity-
>> Definitely.
>> To provide.
Support in terms of credentialing.
>> Right.
>> So how are you
thinking about those various strategies?
Are you sorta executing on all of those at
this point or
do you believe like Steve Ballmer does
that you need one strategy and
you need to do it really well?
>> Well we couldn't succeed by ignoring
all three pieces of that,
of that triangle.
That is we obviously need to appeal to
the, we have to optimize for
the learner experience that it has to be a
really attractive presentation of
the material has to be something people
wanna re-engage in after they try it.
So that's, that's just product design and,
and good pedagogy and
using the research from all the data to
make the user experience better.
We have to please our partners because
our.
As this is Coursera specific now because
you wouldn't have to go to this way, but
our niche in this market is aggregating
content from great Universities.
Many of the other people in the online
education space are using faculty they
hire freelance, which are largely from
industry, not from Universities.
And that's, and
for sorta business skills training, that's
probably a pretty successful model.
That's basically what Udacity is doing.
They're, they're focusing narrowly on the
tech sector.
Hiring industry people to teach courses on
tech skills.
Our, our niche and our asset is
relationships with now 128 Universities.
We're the best in the world.
And I think you know, it makes us
different.
It, it makes the average quality of what
we do way higher, I think,
than any of the competitors, and, and so
we're, we need to keep the partners happy.
And then the business community comes in
because we need people to recognize,
I mean our monetization strategy is
basically education's free.
But if you want verification, a verified,
you know, you want your identity verified.
And getting certified as having completed
the course satisfactorily that
costs $50, basically.
And we are now discounting the price in
some of the developing countries.
And to do that you need, for that to be
something people
want to pay for when it's also free you
need the business community to recognize.
Some of these courses, about half of our
courses are, build skills.
The other half are general education
courses.
At least those half of the courses that
the business community says, oh, yes,
we want people who've taken your data
science specialization, or
we want people who have studied Android
programming on your, on your platform.
I wanna make sure to spend some-
>> Yeah.
>> Time, Rick,
on the fact that you went from really
leading a room full of PhD academics,
to looking out at a room full of MBAs and
product engineers, right?
So how has your leadership style evolved
since, moving.
From a very traditional University into a
start up where you're not
only dealing with a different type of
employee but you're also dealing with two
founders who are still very involved with
the company.
>> It's, there's, it's different, that's
for sure, but but as a general.
As a general matter, there's a lot that's
in common in any leadership position, and,
and I said it, you know,
having a vision, communicating it clearly,
picking the right people,
putting them in the right jobs, enabling
them, not micromanaging them.
You know, those are all lessons that are
very very general.
And and, and,
you know, running Coursera's sort of more,
a little more, it's somewhere in between.
It's sort of what, more like running the
economics department than like running
Yale because it's a, it's a, it's a
smaller population of people.
In the economics department, we had about,
my time, about 50 faculty and, and.
And 30 or 40 staff, so it, it course, a
little bit smaller than Coursera.
But, and so, you know,
you have all hands meetings, you deal with
the whole population.
You didn't do that in a big organization
like Yale.
So you need to have you know, that ability
to listen and
process and or, organize people, delegate
tasks to the right people.
All that's the same.
What's kind of different.
Is the speed of the,
of the required speed of decision making
in this in this internet environment.
I mean, we're in a brand new start up
business were
constantly testing and iterating.
We have to do our product development
rapidly.
Put something out there,
try it, do some testing, improve it,
constantly were just working relentlessly.
Day and night to make the product better
and better.
Make it build new features make them make
them work.
That's just relentless effort on a time
scale of
just higher pressure than your used to in
the University setting.
And then there's questions about making
strategic choices.
You know they're coming at you all the
time.
And just as they are in the University.
But in the University you know everybody's
used to.
Oh let's talk about this for three months
before we decide.
I mean it just th, there's not that sense
of urgency or
well resourced you basically the business
of daily education and
research is gonna go on no matter what the
President does.
And, and so it's different.
But in the, in the small company in a
highly competitive environment where we're
charting new ground.
You have to be prepared to react more
quickly and,
and and actually that means be prepared to
make a few mistakes.
Because you can't get everything right
without a lot of deliberation.
So you, you take some risks.
But that's what makes the world
interesting.
>> Can you share any of those risks that
you've taken that haven't gone so well?
>> Well we haven't made any of those bad
decisions since I've been there.
>> Of course.
>> But there were some made earlier.
[LAUGH]
>> Why even ask?
>> No, I, I I I think, I think there that
we,
we have we have tried to, to work with our
partners, the Universities.
To, to, to renegotiate certain aspects of
our arrangements with them and
we've run into situations where they've
been very adamant about maintaining one or
two of the terms in our original agreement
which I fully understand why it recog,
why it recognizes their interests but on
the other hand.
You know, it's not, not consistent with
sort of, internet norms.
We, we're an internet company, and there
are, there are how, what happens.
Here's a good example.
What happens, this is one we just had a
hard time.
We, we would like to do more to
essentially be able to take down.
Comments on this, on our, in our
interactions on our forums.
When, if, they start to get harassing or
threatening or, or, or are, we've
had some, there are some bad actors, we've
had incidents that are bad incidents.
You know, and, the University perspective
is that we don't take anything down,
we just, we just, you know, we, we, we, we
and certainly it's my policy at Yale,
if, you know, hate speech is responded to
with more speech.
You're basically, you, you tea, use it as
a teaching moment.
You tell the community, this is
inappropriate.
But we're, we're not gonna, we're not
gonna take it,
you know we're not gonna take it down.
But we're, but we're gonna tell you,
we think this is inappropriate and here's
why.
The internet's not like that.
All the big social media places you know
are taking stuff down all the time.
And, and, you know, so getting,
the Universities really aren't ready to
accept that.
They want, they want the University kind
of rules to govern them.
They don’t want an, of Coursera, taking
anything down without their involvement.
And so we made em, we made kind of a
mistake reaching for this, I think.
But, that we backed off and.
Okay, we won't do anything without talking
to you first, but it's just the way,
it's kind of give and take, you see, in
these kinds of situations.
>> You've got a room full of potential
entrepreneurs here,
as well as, people who have a real passion
for education.
So, outside of what Coursera is doing,
what do you see,
as the biggest opportunity for disruption
in education today, and what
advice would you have for the students
here on how to pursue those opportunities.
>> Well doing, yes this,
this new technology does have the
potential to disrupt higher education.
But I think actually-
The near term phenomenon, the phenomena
for
the next decade won't be that universities
as we know them disappear,
it'll be that universities actually have
their impact amplified.
And, and, and become more important to
society by
virtue of having even more people you
know, that they're engaged with.
So that's one thing.
But what, but what in, what in ed tech?
I mean, you know, the promise that ed tech
is
going to deliver miracles has been around
for a long time.
I remember when I started teaching as an
assistant professor at Yale,
all the excitement about what Carnegie
Mellon then called programmed learning.
That, you know, we're going to replace
lectures entirely with
computer drills that are actually all
print based, but
due to this basically take you through
material in a programmed way.
And if you get a wrong answer here, it
leads you to this branch, and
you get the following material, and
if you get a right answer it goes to this
path, and, it, that never happened.
It's still a good idea.
I mean, a modern version of this would be
an idea I had a Yale actually that we
couldn't get high school teachers to
accept which was we wanted to do a,
have Yale Press do a really first-rate
Chinese language,
you know, teaching Chinese to English
language learners.
And my idea was gamify it.
You know, it was basically have, have
voice recognition technology, and
have, and have you say something, you've
confronted an obstacle, in,
in a game you know ,and, and
you have to communicate the words orally
and the computer would fix it.
I thought that would be a great way to
teach, you know, to teach language.
The high school teachers we consulted with
didn't even want to touch it, so.
It's gonna be a long time before there's
really revolutionary disruption in
traditional education.
In the meantime, all this stuff added
around the edges is gonna, like,
like moves for university level stuff.
And like the Khan Academy in material and
other things that focus more on K to 12.
I think it's going to be greatly enriching
for people.
It's gonna make their lives better.
I think it'll, I think it's creating great
social value.
I mean I'd encourage you to think about
you know,
joining a startup and try to help build
something.
The idea that we're gonna completely
disrupt the educational system,
as opposed to just reaching more people
who are outside it, or
improving the experience of those who are
inside it is probably just a little early.
Well I've been speaking a lot here and
asking you a lot of questions, Rick, so
I want to make sure to open it up to our
audience and
we have two mics that will be passed as
well as our hashtag gsbvftt.
So we'll be alternating between questions
from the audience here and
questions that Ryan will read from
Twitter.
So, Brian, do you have one ready to go?
>> Sure, yeah.
So we've gotten a few questions from the
audience on on Coursera and
on your role at Yale.
>> Mm.
>> And one that keeps up
that you might have an interesting
perspective on is,
what's your pitch to colleges or
universities?
Is it solely about amplifying the message
of universities?
How do you deal with the threats they,
they perceive Coursera or
MOOCs having to the traditional model and
is there a, a place for a sort of a moral
responsibility of universities to provide
education to the masses?
>> Yeah, so that is, I mean, the, the, the
scale that this offers has been my,
my principle pitch to universities.
And it's actually a har, it's actually a
kind of a hard sell.
I mean it's not, it's, it's.
[COUGH] I, I think part of what I, what I
have to do personally is, is to,
is to carry that message.
I mean I, I think that it's the, and, and
one of the advantages of having been a
university president and
dealing now with university leaders is I
do have some credibility.
So people are kinda surprised when I say
my first, you know, the first,
the first thing about this is not
improving on campus teaching although it,
it's great for that and will help you do
that.
If that's what you focus on,
you're sort of missing what's really, what
really matters.
So I have been pushing primarily the
notion that
this should redefine the mission of
university.
Our mission, the mission of the university
in,
if you go to most people's missions
statements, will have something to
do with the creation and the dissemination
of knowledge.
Okay, so we create knowledge through our
research.
We disseminate it through our publications
and teaching.
But we publish to increasingly small
audiences.
You know, I mean, many professionals
publish their articles and
are read by, you know, 100 people in their
field.
And that's pretty good.
We disseminate it through teaching.
Okay.
And the teaching, in many places, like
GSB, is wonderful.
But how big are the classes?
And how many students do, does a professor
reach?
This offers a op, you know, you know on
average maybe 100 or
200 students a year is the, is the contact
a faculty member has.
And with the Coursera of course you reach
tens of thousands.
And, and that's revolutionary I think, and
it gives the university
a chance to make a difference to wor, you
know global development.
To, to give economic development
opportunity to people all over the world.
And to give life long learning opportunity
to those who you know,
don't need the economic advancement, but
just are curious.
Just want to learn more, want to grow.
So it's an amazing, I think it's amazing.
That is basically my pitch.
I mean, yes, we'll support your on-campus
with classrooms.
I mean, it's great.
It's, yes we'll give you data.
You can analyze it.
You can figure out which questions in your
quizzes are, are not working.
And you can improve your lectures that
lead up to those questions.
There are a whole lot of things we can do
that way.
And yes we can generate revenue for you,
but frankly, we think we can at least, but
frankly that revenues not, the scale at
which we can do that is not gonna be
a game changer for 128 different
university departments.
We had even if we were distributing half a
billion dollars,
that's not a huge number for universities
you know to have so.
I think it's mainly the,
it's mainly think about about what, what
is the social role of the university?
And technology has enabled universities to
move beyond the education of
the elites of highly selected elites, to
the, the, the world.
And I think that's incredibly powerful.
A question from the audience.
>> I, I'd love to ask about challenging
decisions you had to face kind of at
the end of your time at Yale.
you, you sorry I'm, I'll stand up so you
can.
>> Oh yeah thanks.
>> You were one of
the hardest things you had to deal with at
the end of
your tenure at Yale was expanding the
residential college system.
And obviously running into the financial
crisis.
The the economics of that became
challenging.
>> Yep.
[LAUGH].
>> It was really rumored that one of the
other view for
the top speaker's offered a very large
gift in order to, you know, name one of
those colleges after that person, and it
was rumored that Yale turned that down.
I realize that that conversation is
probably confidential and
don't want you to have to delve too much
into that.
But can you talk a little bit about the
challenge you have as an executive
between profitability and kind of
organizational values and
how you think that situation potentially
exemplifies that and how you
think about that at Coursera as you
obviously deal with a number of, kind of,
important morals and values in education
but also needing to drive profitability?
>> Good question.
So you know, we, we, we have, have.
We put a lot of money into our facilities
and it's only after we
get half mostly renovated that we decided
expansion would be a good idea.
You know, if you know the Yale system we
have these very, particularly since
they've been renovated, amazing facilities
to house undergraduates that are.
That create social environments and
great communities and have amazing you
know, facilities to support that.
We wanted to build two more.
It was high, high on the agenda right
before the crisis hit.
And along with a lot of other capital
projects that we
just basically froze at that point.
I, I won't confirm or deny the, the rumor
you heard.
But I will say this, I think that, so we
basically committed,
decided at the time of the financial
crisis that if we were going to go
forward with colleges, we're going to have
to raise 100% of the money.
We, we, we, that we going to have to be
essentially an all cash transaction.
We weren't gonna take new debt to finance
the new colleges.
And we would have to absorb the
incremental operating cost and
operating budget.
We would have to have enough, you know,
projected future surplus so
we could do that.
So all, it was, it we were not gonna rob
anything existing in order to,
in order to expand.
There's no question that had we wanted to
allow
donors to name these colleges, we probably
could have raised a substantially greater,
we, we, we're, you know, we're naming
towers and, and courtyards and entryways.
But the, the names of the Yale colleges,
you know,
originally were selected by the Yale
Corporation to honor, you know,
important founders of the university or
great Yale, you know, Yale-worthies.
Great, great, great citizens and
contributors to public life or
intellectual life who came from Yale.
And my board did not wanna name a college
for a donor.
And I, I, I have to say.
I, I ha, I was very ambivalent actually on
that subject personally,
because I really wanted to see this
project go forward and
we have lots of things named for donors
at, at, at, at Yale, but
I, I saw the argument and I, and it was a
pretty overwhelmingly I mean the,
the Yale Corporation which is a small,
very highly deliberative body.
Was pretty strong about this.
And so we had to disappoint at least one
prospective donor, who,
who would have, who would have done this.
I maybe, I guess, didn't answer it.
The general question is yes, there's
always a tension between values and prac-,
and practicality.
But I, I have to say, at an institution
like Yale, the choice comes down on
the side of values way more often than
not.
And, and and actually I would say this
is probably more salient for all of you,
take it out of the Yale context.
I mean, one of the things I always ask
myself.
It whenever we had a tough issue,
any, any tough issue was what is the right
thing to do.
I mean that is you can make all kinds of
expedient arguments on one
side or another.
And it's the temptations when you're
running a big institution like Yale.
Because it is so much in the public view
and so
much of what you do is scrutinized by so
many different people there is always
a temptation to say, oh, this is one we
can sort of hide.
We don't have to deal with it.
We can shove it under the rug.
You can't, you just can't.
There is nothing,
nothing gets shoved under the rug, I mean
basically, you have to assume.
I, I, I live my life like I had to assume
that everything I did or
said could appear in the New York Times.
I mean, it, you just, you just, you can't
hide anything.
So you might as well live by your values
because in the long run,
that's the best way to live.
>> Could you respond to the second part of
the question.
>> Yeah.
>> Relating back to the-
>> Yeah you know I still, I still, I still
feel that way,
it's just, it's a little it's a it, it
the, the profit motive, it,
it means that one of your objectives at
least is, you know, to make something.
You gotta be sustainable, you've gotta
bring your terms to your, to your owners.
that's, but that's a value that also has
to be weighed against the mission.
I.
>> [COUGH]
>> You know, you know,
we haven't decided if Coursera to become a
B corporation, but it, a, a company like
Coursera is certainly a candidate for that
because we do have a mission, which is to
deliver you know, to deliver universal
access to the world's best education.
And we all believe in it and we wouldn't
have had, we wouldn't have succeed in
getting the great employees that we have
managed to attract without that mission.
If we were just another tech start up
with, you know,
that wanted to make a lot of money.
I don't think we would have done, we, we,
we are competing with Google and
Facebook for engineers.
Some of our senior execs have left
companies like Google, Facebook, Netflix,
to come join us.
So, you know, they're not there,
they're really not there because they
think we're going to get rich.
I mean we may all get rich, but that's not
why we're there.
We're there because we think this is a
important issue.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
A question from this side?
>> Going back to the theme of universities
[INAUDIBLE].
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Well, yeah.
So, let's start with why you should still
pay.
I, I, I paid two years of actually more.
My, my daughter took an engineering degree
too.
So and I paid a lot of undergraduate
tuitions at Stanford.
Four you know, three times four.
So and I'd pay it.
The and, and and it's still worth it
because what you get in
the live experience with such amazing
fellow students and, and
with the live contact with mentors and
professors.
It, it, we're not gonna be able to supply
that on the internet anytime soon.
I mean what where making available and
democratizing is essentially the content.
So if you wanna master content the, the,
coursera is a great tool.
I, I if you wanna, you know, really do a
deep dive
into forming relationships that are going
to mean something to you for a lifetime.
To learn all the soft skills, and, and,
and interpersonal skills, and
skills of leadership, and fellowship, and
teamwork that you need in life.
There's nothing like these great
universities.
There's just no experience comparable.
It's a, this is an immersion experience
with a lot of brilliant people, you know,
who have enormous potential to do great
things in the world.
And you get to benefit from it.
It's worth many times what you pay for it
actually.
So, so.
I, I don't think, you know, GSB is [LAUGH]
Is going down,
down any time soon to the internet.
I'm not worried about that.
So I think the, you know, I think things
are re, I think it can be reconciled.
Now the, the, the question does come up,
what hap, but what about the experiences
that really aren't like this?
So, what about, what about second tier.
Third tier institutions that basically
aren't residential.
Aren't, don't have communities.
People commute in to to a community
college, take a course and they go home.
I mean, could the internet, you know.
Could, could a Coursera replace that?
I think the answer is yes.
It could.
You know,
it could become a cheaper, more effective
way.
The so to learn, to learn what students
having that kind of experience can learn.
So there, yes it will have caused some
kind of disruption and
there will be some dis some dis relocation
of of students towards
just getting credentials online rather
than getting degrees.
How massive a change it will be over what
time frame I'm, I'm my guess is.
Moderate, and
over a [LAUGH] long time frame rather than
a lot sent over a short one.
>> Another question from Twitter.
>> sure.
This one's from Gabe Alazondo, and
it touches on something you just mentioned
a little bit.
>> Right.
>> That the disruption of higher ed is
going very slowly, and you've seen that
over time.
Is the main missing ingredient the student
interaction that you just spoke about?
And if so, how do you feel about sort of
hybrid models like the Minerva project or
other companies that might be
trying to combine mass education with
those student student engagement models?
>> Well, Minerva's not a good example,
that's ultra small scale.
That's not, so that's a that's a
different, that's using both online and
and live methods for a very highly
selective group that's.
I think different the I think yeah the
missing pieces so
far are not for it's, it's the it's the
network effects of bringing everybody
together into one physical location that
which is both peer to peer learning and,
and learning social skills.
And it's also critical thinking because
the classroom experience which could be
replicated online I think with live video
chat but
that would have to be small scale.
I mean you, you I don't think you could
have 2,000 students online and
do the, do the kind of critical thinking.
Tool development that's sort of the, the,
the questioning, the forcing you to defend
an argument.
I mean, that's very personalized.
And it works very well in a 15 person
seminar.
It works even better in an Oxford tutorial
but, but
these are not the things that, that the
internet can replicate.
So it's, so it's a number,
you know it's the re, it's the, it's the
whole residential on campus experience.
It's a big part of it and and it's the
intimate contact with faculty and
it's and it's the highly interactive
classroom.
all, all of those are ingredients of what
you get in the, we,
we are not delivering now.
I think technology can deliver some of
that but not all of it.
>> Sorry, can you stand up and.
>> When you mentioned the [UNKNOWN] having
companies hire people that have done
some of the courses that you-
>> Yeah.
>> Made available.
Is there any help that you can give to for
example emerging?
Are you, the question is how do you help,
how can you help companies in emerging
markets to, to, to decipher what are the
courses that might be valuable to them?
And, yeah, yeah, the.
This is a work in progress, but it's
something we're very mindful of.
And so yes we've talked to a bunch of
large
global companies who employ people around
the world, and try to elicit from them
what kinds of courses are valuable, what I
expect will happen hasn't happened yet.
But I, I'd love to see, actually on our
site, a kind of posting that,
you know, Price Waterhouse Coopers
recommends that's a global company,
it has over a million employees
world-wide.
Recommends these five courses, or these
ten courses; these would be useful to us,
to us.
I mean and I I and I you know we've had
conversations with some of
the corporations about this and I think, I
think we'll get there in the next year.
Probably have some of that and that will
be a helpful guide.
Basically allow companies to to
demonstrate you know
indicate what courses they they want.
Obviously they can do it in their job.
Rex as well.
So but you know actually posting guide
post on our site would actually
have externalities because of the P.W.C.
says this is a valued course for us.
A smaller accounting firm in you know in
Latin America could could look at that and
say yeah that that makes sense to us too.
Yeah.
>> Well, we're about to run out of time
Rick, but
I do want to end with one question that I
think will, will speak to a lot of
people in the audience because it's on the
GSB application.
And that question is, what matters most to
you and why?
[LAUGH]
>> I'm tempted to say that the Giants win
the World Series.
[LAUGH] Because I'm a lifelong fan.
[SOUND] But that's, that would be
frivolous.
[LAUGH] When I got appointed exceed, a
little side line,
when I got appointed president of Yale I
was asked by the New York Times,
is this the most exciting day of your
life?
And I responded no, not as exciting as
when the Giants moved to San Francisco.
I was eleven years old.
My wife almost killed me with that remark.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I mean the birth of our children, you
know, I mean.
[LAUGH] There are some things more
important.
[LAUGH]
>> But what matters between, I, I,
you know, it, it, it may sound trivial and
trite and
it can be said by many people, but making,
making a difference in the world.
I mean doing, I, I come out of you know, a
tradition.
I had a mother who raised me to sort of
understand you know.
You're a person with a good mind, and
you have an obligation to, you know, to
make a difference in the world.
I mean, do something of value to others.
So, I'd say that's what matters to me.
>> Well, thank you so much, Rick.
[APPLAUSE].
[MUSIC]